[Musique]
oui bien à paroles attaque l'anticiper
savoir lundi puis cette semaine il fait
très beau pré show et je sais pas si
vous êtes comme moi mais vous sentez la
proche des élections qui risquent d'être
dégagé ou d'avoir déclenché depuis que
j'enregistrais chronique
si vous avez suivi les dernières
chroniques que j'ai fait ou je parle
justement du milieu politique donne que
je parle de la scène politique
autochtone du paysage politique
justement au sein de paysages canadiens
et québécois
par le passé j'ai fait plusieurs
chroniques où je parlais justement je
vais chez les communautés autochtones la
politique des systèmes politiques c'est
quand même très important c'est quand
même un système qui régit
comment nous communauté fonctionne
comment notre présence dans les villes
fonctionnent les
que ça aide des enjeux qui touchent y
joyce et chaque pointe par exemple où
les enfants qui ont été retrouvés sur
les personnages tout ce qui est
autochtone est très politique et très
politisé fait partie de systèmes
politiques qui ont été mis en place sans
ou avec nous
mais il ya encore beaucoup d'enjeu à
découvrir beaucoup de direction avec
elle on s'enligne qui ne sont pas encore
claires qui sont à découvrir de plus en
plus l'intérêt des politiciens du milieu
politique des partis politiques autour
des enjeux autochtones se fait sentir
certains sont en a créé vraiment dans un
désir de justice sociale qui existe
depuis très longtemps dans ces parties
de d'autres sites parce que il ya quand
même un réveil collectif autour des
enjeux et certains groupes politiques
eux c'est carrément
d'opportunisme parce qu'on a vu par le
passé c'est ces partis politiques par
exemple
bénéficier justement
manque d'accessibilité à de la justice
des communautés pour pouvoir passer des
enfants des projets sur le territoire
vous comprenez que c'est dynamique sont
encore en train de faire découvrir
encore après de développer puisqu'on
parle quand même
d'une justice qui se développe dans le
temps
ce qui est drôle c'est que souvent on
peut regarder le paysage politique
américain et canadien
avoir totalement de paysage politique
totalement différent mais quand on
regarde celui concerné communauté
autochtone il ya des très grandes
différences comme le fait que aux états
unis il n'y a pas de loi sur les indiens
le système en place des réserves et des
bottes notre manière totalement
différent donc ça fait des enjeux qui
sont clairement en avance ici dans la
discussion comme les femmes assassinées
et disparues
les enfants qui sont trouvés dans les
pensionnats justement dans le système
des pensionnats qui n'ont pas eu d
commission denquête comme celle qui a eu
au canada donc à une avancée au canada
qui est plus grande que celle aux etats
unis cependant il ya un autre enjeu et
c'est celui du vote autochtone qui est
beaucoup plus actifs aux états unis au
canada pourquoi est la loi sur les
indiens fait en sorte que les systèmes
politiques en place dans nos communautés
sont différents de ceux qui sont au
canada au québec est donc en regardant
comment la fnme-cgt été mis en place
beaucoup de gens voter dans un système
canadien ça veut dire accepter la
colonisation ça veut dire céder ses
droits donc pour beaucoup de charles
l'attrait des élections n'est pas la
même que aux états unis où la vie est
vraiment défaut de distinction de nation
ce gouvernement mais un excès aux
élections qui permettent de faire
changer les choses et aux dernières
élections présidentielles un changement
énorme est venu avec le vote autochtone
justement dans des régions comme
l'arizona où les populations autochtones
puisque cd des régions qui sont moins
occupé par les communautés
américaines mais beaucoup par des
communautés autochtones ont pu faire
basculer justement les élections en
faveur
d'un autre parti donc il ya un événement
autour de tout ce qu'on voit qu'il ya
une capacité ou comme par les
communautés autochtones dû au fait
qu'ils habitent dans des régions
éloignées qui peuvent aborder les
pouvoirs politiques assez fort de
pouvoir transformer le vote donc de plus
en plus de jeunes vont voter vont toutes
les ressources à leur disposition pour
transformer le paysage canadien
personnellement
j'utilise
pour pouvoir transformer le plus
possible aux paysages qui me concerne
pas que famille nous depuis depuis que
je peux voter mais c'est certain que
dans mon idéal politique j'aimerais qu'à
une partie concerne beaucoup plus les
communautés autochtones de façon directe
et qui permettrait d'avoir vraiment pro
politique sur le visage qui avec moi et
sur le paysage qu'elle était peut-être
plus comme des organismes qui ont quand
même écoute des partis politiques plus
que c'était un groupe a conçu alors
prévoir comment je suis intéressé que
mangeurs de voir ce qui va se passer de
voir comment les parties vont se mettre
de l'avant auprès des goodies électeurs
autochtone mais aussi des électeurs
québécois et canadiens et de voir
comment la dynamique va se dérouler
cette année surtout dans un camp de kobe
dans une période où
il ya des promesses électorales des
dernières élections qui n'ont pas encore
été mis en place l'eau courante les 94
appel à l'action de la commission vérité
réconciliation il ya beaucoup de choses
qui on va voir et on espère quand même
une transformation et à chaque élection
aux voix du changement pour pas négliger
que certains partis ont carrément mis de
côté l'idée de pouvoir faire bénéficier
aux communautés autochtones justement de
cette justice canadienne mais d'autres
travaillent très fort à se transformer
et d'autres sont beaucoup plus en avance
que les autres partis pour faire
entendre les voix autochtone et c'est
sûr que c'est une synergie entre toutes
les communautés au canada qui peut
amener cette justice pour les
communautés autochtones et justement la
participation des communautés
autochtones sur leur propre territoire
dans une population est beaucoup plus en
plus mélanger beaucoup plus en plus
intersectionnelle dans les enjeux alors
vous comprenez c'est excitant et
j'espère que vous allez suivre les
élections ou de façon aussi intéressé
que moi je vais faire dans les
prochaines semaines alors c'est une
belle semaine n'hésitez pas à partager
ses vidéos et ce n'est pas allé
consulter les autres chroniques que j'ai
fait par le parti sur cet enjeu 25 m